- Prêts à partir pour une
mission 100 et 150 hommes et fes
en uniforme seront bientôt
déployés en Pologne, afin
d'aller prêter main-forte aux
Ukrainiens qui fA A A A A A A Ae
de la Défense nationale
- Notre personnel fournira
un soutien général,
des servdes soins médicaux limic
l'aide de membres ukrainophones
des Forces armées canadiennes.
- La crise humanitaire
continue de s'aggraver.
Plus de quatre millions de
110 000 d'entre elles ont choisi
le Canada comme sanctu...
Les agents canadiens
d'immigration sur le terrain
- Afin de contribuer aux soins
immédiats et auxitititements
des réfugiés ukrainiens.
- Un pas dans la bonne
s'attendait à plus.
LUC BERTchchchchef adjoint de
l'opposition officielle, Ottawa
- On ne sait pas encoreexexexexe
vont jouer ces militaiàààà en
Pologne. On ne sait pas non
plus, dans l'annonce qui a été
ces soldats vont être déployés.
ALEXANDRE BOULERICE,
chef adjoint, NPD
du gouvernement libéral est
assez timide a a a a des pays
qui en font beaucoup plus
que nous en ce moment.
une mission d'ordre humanitaire
n'est  s s s solution idéale,
selon cet expert.
FRANÇOIS AUDET, Instit. d'études
- Si les militaires débarquent
là, il y adedededes combattants,
et ils sont susceptibles
notamment d'être une cible,
par ex y y y y y y y y y y y y ,
premièrement.
- Dans des missions précédentes,
des militaires qui occupaient
de
certaines informations
recueillies auprès de réfugiés
à des fins stratégiques.
- Et ce genre de situation-là,
l'impartialité des zones
humanitairesvevevevevers
la présence de militaires,
peut créer
- Pendant ce temps,
les reche e e e e poursuivent
à Boutcha pour déterminer
si les
des fosses communes ont été
victcrcrcrcrcrime de guerre.
On ne sait toujours pas
qu
se joindront à eux. Ils doivent
cocococococompléter leur formatn
au Canada et à La Haye.
Et pendant que nos alliés
de plus en plus sophistiqué
à l'armée ukrainienne,
les 500 millions de dollars
promis dans le budget
par le Canadeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaer
parlementaire, Bloc québécois
- Ça moueueueueueuel point
le Canada n'était pas prêt
à donner un coup de pouce
à la l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'.
- Les Britanniques envoient
de a a a a a antinavires.
Les Américains, eux,
des véhicules blindés
Quant au Canada, il se prépare
à envoyer des camér
définition afin d'équiper
les drones de surveillance.
Radio-Canada, Ottaw